- Let me just read you this headline
and you tell me what it sounds like.
"JK Rowling's Giant Bush Is Causing
"Traffic Mayhem in Edinburgh".
(upbeat jazz music)
Beloved children's author JK Rowling
is trimming her bush outside.
This is wreaking havoc
on the Twitter-sphere.
So I'm gonna find out what
our office mates think
by askin' 'em and tellin' 'em about it.
Who is this woman?
- That is JK Rowling.
- JK Rowling.
- If you heard she was
outside trimming her bush
what would you think?
- That's pretty indecent.
- Do you think it's in a lightning bolt?
"JK Rowling's Giant Bush Is Causing
"Traffic Mayhem in Edinburgh".
- I got you JK.
- Obviously it's about a tree bush.
- Is it obvious?
- Her new book, bush, is causing traffic.
Like, people are rushing to the stores
to try to get the book.
- Sounds like JK's got
a wardrobe malfunction.
- I'm not even surprised,
happens all the time.
That bush gets in the way a lot.
- [Man Interviewing] What
do you think that's about?
- (laughs) JK Rowling's bush?
- [Man Interviewing] "JK
Rowling causes road rage
by trimming her bush.
- I think that's an overreaction.
- Yeah?
- I wouldn't get angry by it.
- These are Cliff Beattie titles.
- You think the're Cliff Bait?
- She's not picking up the
pieces of the bush she cut off?
- It sounds like pubic
hair but I'm guessing
that it's landscaping.
- [Man] Right.
- I saw that she was running around
in traffic with a pair of scissors.
- Yeah.
- And the bush, ouch.
- I mean doesn't something like that
happen in "Harry Potter"?
- I'm assuming that this bush
is attached to her house.
- [Man Interviewing] "Harry
Potter and the prisoner
"of the traffic jam: JK
Rowling causes four days
"of travel chaos after installing
temporary traffic lights
"so she can have her
Laylandii bush trimmed".
Is it Laylandii?
- Yes, that's a very
English bush actually.
- Sounds like a fancy kind of bush.
- She just installed a light and a lot
of people are upset by it.
- Why'd she install the light?
- So that she could get her bush trimmed.
- What do you think about that?
- Well I mean I think
that's kind of selfish.
- It's a boring story made
popular by a gross use of words.
Well I guess what we learned here today
is that nobody is safe, even in Europe,
from having something
about their private life
be turned into a Cliff Beattie title
about just their privates.
- JK Rowling's landscaping takes a spell.
Quidditch, more like quit it, JK Rowling.
- Looks like Rowlings should
have been more of a Potter.